alright 2013 starting off with a sound
of some sort it's not quite a bang but
it's a sound Texas Chainsaw 3d so Texas
Chainsaw 3d is another Texas Chainsaw
Massacre movie is it a reboot is it a
sequel here's how has gone down as I
understand it Texas Chainsaw Massacre
came out in 1974 then I had a couple of
sequels and had a movie I think it was a
reboot it sounds like it was a reboot it
has the words next generation in the
title so I'm saying reboot but that
doesn't really matter because they
rebooted it in 2003 with Michael Bay's
producer and then that movie got a
prequel showing how leather face became
leather face now we have Texas Chainsaw
3d Texas Chainsaw 3d is actually a
sequel to the original Texas Chainsaw
Massacre movie which is what Texas
Chainsaw Massacre 2 was I imagine but no
now Texas Chainsaw 3d is the official
sequel to the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
negating all sequels and reboots that
ever came after the original Texas
Chainsaw Massacre movie in hopes of
being fresh and new yet sticking with
the roots and did it succeed I don't
know it depends on whether or not the
roots are a piece of [ __ ] look I'm not
even gonna [ __ ] you guys are string
you along I'm just gonna explain to you
why this movie is terrible first of all
the acting you see the actors you're
like these people are really attractive
the main chick is this really hot
brunette chick she always has these crop
top shirts it shows her little waist and
her abs not only she extremely
attractive but her friend's hot too but
hot in that [ __ ] kind of way and the
dudes are really attractive bad actors
also this one cop guys like hi I'm a cop
how you doing hey I'll see you later you
know I'm gonna be in the movie later
because I look like I just got off the
set of a CW show I couldn't get the part
in arrow so now I'm in this movie so on
the plot of this piece of [ __ ] this hot
chick inherits this mansion of course
leather faces in this mansion so now he
just starts tearing people up all the
while any shot of the crew walking
automatically is a shot of the hot
chicks asses as they walk away from the
camera and you know that's all well and
good I have to touch on how hot the
chicks are in this movie because that's
the positive that I took away from this
I'm like oh yeah hot chicks awesome but
as being a reviewer I have to be able to
pull myself away from that situation and
mentally go but is the movie good no it
is not that may not sound like much but
for guys it's a superpower we're not
born with the ability to do that we have
to really
developed that years and years of
strenuous practice and being a nerd in
high school and rejection taught me to
think with this not even majority at a
time but you know when it comes to
videos I take this [ __ ] seriously the
dialogues terrible the script is abysmal
it's like Halloween
h2o where you're like alright so they're
going back and making a sequel to a
movie that was like 20 years ago
thirty years forty years ago time does
fly in the movie world and you're like
whoa that was your shot now it's over
Halloween h2o had Joseph gordon-levitt
in it trivial knowledge there this movie
has nobody nobody in this movie will
ever ever be big one day then you look
at it in the productions not even that
good just seeing where this guy's
chained up in leather faces just slicing
him in half and he's squirming he's like
my god and then it shows his torso being
cut in half and it's not moving at all
so it's like oh my god still shot
cutting oh my god till torso cutting not
squirming so in the year 2000 hit the
hole squirming person but still shot of
a dummy being cut in half that's clearly
a dummy because it's not squirming I
thought we were done with that
apparently we're not Texas Chainsaw 3d
reminds us of that you would swear to
god this movie was made to come out
straight to DVD not even Netflix just
DVD in a gas station somewhere only
reason it's not because it needs to be
in 3d so when Leatherface is swinging
his chainsaw it's all like oh it's
coming after your face is so close to
the 3d 3d gimmick [ __ ] and there is
a time paradox to our Texas Chainsaw
Massacre came out in 1974 I always
assumed the movie took place in 1974
people certainly dressed like the 70s in
the original Texas Chainsaw Massacre and
it shows flashbacks at the beginning of
this movie and everyone is from the 70s
because of stock footage of the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre all right now the main
chick in this movie looks about 19 years
old so let's say this is 19 years later
otherwise known as the early 90s is it
the early nineties though is it really
because there's a scene where a cop is
walking through the house with his gun
and a smartphone so there are a couple
of options here one the main chick in
this movie is about 40 years old
probably not typically they had
smartphones in the early 90s probably
not or three the original Texas Chainsaw
Massacre movie now takes place in the
early 90s in which everyone dresses like
the 70s in the 90s actually I think that
was a thing people did dress like the
70s in the 90s oh they didn't do that
until the mid to late 90s oh you know
what I'm not even going to talk about it
anymore why because I don't want to
think about it anymore why because no
one should ever think about Texas
Chainsaw 3d as much as I already have
Texas Chainsaw 3d is [ __ ] I told you
start
off of something it's just not a bang
it's a dog [ __ ] sound that sound right
so 2013 what are your new year's
resolutions you know you might as well
put in the comments section what you're
not going to hold to and actually follow
through with because that's just fun
otherwise if you want to hold it close
to the chest and actually follow through
with it you don't want to put it in the
comments section jinxing it I understand
in which case I will ask you what is the
worst slasher flick you've ever seen in
your life whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more